[music playing]
MORGAN FREEMAN: The Cao Dai
religion, an unusual blend
of eastern and western
faiths, appears
to be flourishing in Vietnam.
Across the country, there
are almost 400 temples.
Followers worship openly.
But it wasn't always that way.
I've been offered an
audience with Cao Dai
senior cardinal [inaudible]
to understand the religion's
secretive history.
How do you do, sir?
Very pleased to meet you.
Can you give me a brief
history of the religion?
[vietnamese]
INTERPRETER: The
purpose of Caodaism
is to unite the traditions of
all religions in the world.
[vietnamese]
INTERPRETER: Caodaism was
established in Vietnam in 1926.
And Vietnam, at that time,
was under the control
of the French administration.
I understood that
some of your leaders
were imprisoned by the French.
Is that so?
CARDINAL: [vietnamese]
INTERPRETER: There was
some misunderstanding
between the French and
Caodaism at the time.
[vietnamese]
INTERPRETER: The leader
was arrested and sent
in exile for five years.
But after that, when they
understood the purpose
of this religion, the French
administration let His Holiness
to be returned to Vietnam.
MORGAN FREEMAN: But
Caodaist struggles
did not end with the French.
In 1943, they took up arms
against Japanese invaders.
The Cao Dai army established
a semi autonomous state
in the Mekong Delta that
survived for a decade
after the Japanese left.
When the communists took
control of Vietnam in 1975,
Caodaism was banned for
more than two decades.
It wasn't just because the
government feared Cao Dai's
military history, or
its blending of faiths
from all over the world.
It was also because of the
secret ceremony that lay
at the heart of the religion.
[vietnamese]
So those mediums were used
to establish the religion.
[vietnamese]
INTERPRETER: Those mediums
received a message from God
to establish and write
down religious regulations,
the constitutions.
And now, we use those as
the basis of Caodaism.
MORGAN FREEMAN: The
details of what happened
in these seances
is still secret,
known only by high dignitaries.
What is known is that there
were always two mediums
controlling some
sort of instrument--
someone to read the
instrument, and a secretary
to write down the message.
When the Vietnamese government
made it legal to practice
the Cal Dai religion in
1997, one of the conditions
was that seances
would remain banned.